Buonasera.
C'era una volta a Roma un fioraio che si chiamava Antonio Spiritichio.
Era un fioraio ambulante, era uno che aveva un posto fisso dove parcheggiava il furgone
e poi apriva la serranda e dal furgone vendeva i suoi fiori.
Un giorno di marzo del 1978 scendendo in strada al mattino per andare a lavorare,
il fioraio trovò che qualcuno gli aveva bucato una gomma.
Avrà detto qualche parolaccia.
Ha cambiato la gomma e alle 9 del mattino era puntuale al lavoro.
Un paio di giorni dopo scendendo al mattino per andare a lavorare,
il fioraio trovò che il furgone aveva tutte quattro le gomme tagliate.
Deveva aver detto molte parolacce quella mattina.
Si è messo lì, ha provato a cambiare le gomme e alla fine ci è riuscito però niente da fare.
Nel mattino al lavoro ha fatto tardi.
Era la mattina del 16 marzo 1978 e il luogo dove il fioraio di solito lavorava dal furgone parcheggiato
era via stresa angolo via Mario Fani.
Non so se la data e il nome vi ricorderebbero qualcosa
se non fosse che sapete qual è l'argomento del nostro incontro di stasera.
Quello era il giorno in cui le brigate rosse avevano progettato di rapire al domoro
e l'angolo tra via stresa e via Mario Fani è il punto preciso
in cui avevano deciso di bloccare le macchine di moro e rapirlo.
Per cui al processo delle BR, in seguito venne fuori che loro,
studiando la scena dell'Aguato, si erano accorti che il fioraio stava proprio nel punto in cui
si sarebbe fermata la macchina di moro e soprattutto quella dietro della scorta.
Il fioraio si sarebbe trovato nella linea di tiro del gruppo di fuoco che doveva sterminare la scorta
e i brigatisti non avevano voglia di fare vittime inutili
perciò avevano deciso che quel mattino il fioraio non doveva esserci.
Avevano fatto una prova generale qualche giorno prima tagliandogli una gomma.
Niente, quello alle nove era lì lo stesso.
Allora il giorno dell'Aguato hanno deciso di andarci giù pesanti.
Gli hanno tagliato tutte e quattro le gomme.
Mario Moretti racconterà poi, o meglio racconterà, dirà capite in che situazione eravamo.
Se per caso quel mattino qualcosa andava a storte dovevamo rimandare a un altro giorno,
quell'altro giorno di nuovo dovevamo tagliargli tutte e quattro le gomme.
E dice Moretti, quante volte potevamo farlo?
A parte che a Spiriticchio sarebbe venuto l'esaurimento nervoso, dice Moretti.
E comunque prima o poi qualcuno avrebbe cominciato a sospettare qualcosa.
Ecco, la storia che racconteremo stasera è fatta anche di questi particolari.
Ha scritto uno storico che si è occupato a lungo del caso Moro,
che studiare questa pagina di storia italiana significa immergersi
in una dimensione orribile, fatta quasi esclusivamente di morti ammazzati e di menzogne.
È vero, però è anche vero che ricostruire questa vicenda,
cioè come le BR hanno progettato e diseguito il rapimento di Moro,
perché questo è il tema di stasera.
Vuol dire anche scoprire tante cose inaspettate, tanti dettagli inattesi.
Su cosa voleva dire essere una rete clandestina di terroristi
e preparare un attentato nell'Italia degli anni 70.
È il caso di fare una premessa anche oggi, facciamola.
Io cercherò di raccontarvi dei fatti accertati.
I fatti accertati in discussi permettono di ricostruire quasi tutta la dinamica del rapimento di Moro.
Poi al di là di questo ci sono le illazioni.
Ci sono i teoremi, ci sono le teorie tirate per i capelli,
ci sono le testimonianze contraddittorie su cui qualcuno ha costruito ipotesi alternative.
Io personalmente credo molto poco a quasi tutte le dietrologie che sono state pubblicate
intorno all'azione delle Brigate Rosse in quei giorni.
Quello che vi racconterò oggi è quello che viene fuori dalle testimonianze,
dai processi, dai verbali, dai libri che i protagonisti hanno scritto,
rimangono molte piccole zone d'ombra, rimangono molti dettagli contraddittori.
Io non credo che nella sostanza che veramente ci importa,
rimangano molte cose che non si sanno.
C'è gente in Italia che pensa invece di sì che ci siano grandi segreti ancora da scoprire.
Io non ci credo tanto.
Comunque questa è la versione che si può mettere insieme mettendo in fila le cose di cui siamo abbastanza sicuri.
E cominciamo con le Brigate Rosse. Che cos'erano le Brigate Rosse?
Mario Moretti, che citerò ancora molto spesso, sono giorni che mi dico,
devi stare attento a non chiamarlo Nanni Moretti, mi scapperà di sicuro.
Mario Moretti, che è uno dei protagonisti e il regista del delitto moro,
ha raccontato molto.
Ovviamente ha raccontato quello che voleva lui.
Non dobbiamo pensare che la sua testimonianza sia candida,
come non sono candidi delle testimonianze di ministri dell'interno o di generali dei carabinieri.
Ma comunque Mario Moretti ha raccontato molto.
E secondo lui le BR erano una vanguardia ristrettissima.
Erano in pochi, molto pochi.
Però in fabbrica avevano un vasto consenso, Moretti è sicuro.
Erano pochi perché avevano deciso che i militanti, irregolari come li chiamavano loro,
che è un termine militare.
È interessante questo. Le Brigate Rosse usano una terminologia militare.
Si sentono un esercito.
Irregolari è stato deciso che vivranno in totale clandestinità.
Nomi falsi, documenti falsi.
Ovviamente questa è una cosa complessa.
Perciò i regolari sono molto pochi.
Qualche decina al massimo in ognuna delle grandi città in cui le BR sono presenti.
Però hanno una vasta rete di fiancheggiatori.
Ci sono un sacco di compagni che vivono la loro vita normale, alla luce del sole,
ma in segreto guardano con simpatia le BR e quando possono danno una mano.
Le BR sono organizzate, come ci ricordiamo da quei tempi, in Colonne.
È un altro termine militare.
In ogni città l'organizzazione delle BR si chiama la Colonna romana, la Colonna genovese.
Ogni Colonna è completamente autonoma.
Risponde sia un esecutivo centrale, ma non sa niente delle altre Colonne.
E questo è un principio fondamentale per sopravvivere in clandestinità.
Meno sai e meno racconterai quando ti arresteranno.
Si chiama la compartimentazione.
Le Colonne nascono in una città quando si è sicuri che in quella città c'è un terreno favorevole.
Anzi raccontano loro quando da quella città ci mandavano a chiamare.
Quando c'è una rete di gente che ci guarda con simpatia, così fitta che riescono a trovarci, riescono a contattarci,
ci chiedono di andarli, allora noi mandavamo dei compagni in città
e verificavamo se era possibile mettere in piedi una nuova Colonna.
La Colonna romana, che è quella che gestisce嫌 il delitto moro,
e cioè l'azione più eclatante delle BR, non è una delle più forti.
La forza delle BR stava nelle grandi città industriali, a Bilano, a Torino, a Genova.
Mario Moretti sostiene che anche a Roma in realtà una certa forza alla fine la avevano.
Anche a Roma c'era qualche fabbrica. Moretti dice c'era una fabbrica dove avevamo un nucleo,
una brigata dicono loro, una fabbrica di Pomezia.
Altri nuclei erano imposti, come dire, che sono più quelli che ci potremmo aspettare
in una grande città come Roma alla SIP, negli ospedali,
e poi nuclei nei quartieri popolari, nelle Borgate, al Tiburtino, a Centocelle, a Prima Valle.
Moretti racconta che le BR e a Roma in realtà erano forti.
Altri brigatisti hanno raccontato una storia un po' diversa.
In particolare c'è un testimone importantissimo, Valerio Morucci.
Voglio stare attenti a non confonderli, Moretti e Morucci.
Morucci, saranno tutti e due in Viafani, al momento della guato a Moro,
però poi le loro strade si sono divise.
Morucci si è dissociato ed è molto critico nei confronti di quel periodo, Moretti molto meno.
E dunque Morucci dice, Moretti esagera, non è mica vero che le Brigate Rossi erano forti a Roma, erano quattro gatti.
E Valerio Morucci dice, io lo so, perché quando io e la mia fidanzata abbiamo chiesto di entrare nelle BR,
fidanzata ed Adriana Faranda.
Morucci e Faranda avevano militato in un'altra organizzazione, INAP, i nuclei armati proletari.
Poi nell'estate del 1976 hanno chiesto di entrare nelle BR.
E Morucci dice, ci hanno subito presi, non solo ci hanno subito presi,
ci hanno subito fatti entrare come militanti a tempo pieno, regolari, clandestini.
E dice Morucci, cito.
Se ci facevano entrare subito come regolari, spocchiosi come erano,
voleva dire che non stavano messi poi tanto bene.
Morucci è uno che è entrato nelle BR dopo aver fatto altre esperienze e poi si è dissociato
e nel suo ricordo tende a insistere.
Ci siamo noi che siamo arrivati dopo e poi c'erano i brigatisti veri.
E quelli erano spocchiosi.
È una cosa che è importante perché fa emergere una delle tante cose che bisogna ricordare,
che le BR non sono monolitiche.
Ci sono i militanti della prima ora, i puri e i duri e poi ci sono quelli che sono arrivati dopo.
Ci sono quelli che hanno fatto altre esperienze, che col tempo maturano dei dubbi.
Ci sono tutto meno che monolitiche le BR.
Però al tempo del rapimento di Moro quei dubbi non sono ancora venuti fuori.
A un certo punto le BR decidono che devono dimostrare la loro forza.
Devono dimostrare la loro forza, rapiranno e processeranno uno dei capi della DC.
È una decisione che matura fra il 76 e il 77.
Su questo le testimonianze sono un po' contraddittorie, devono averne parlato a lungo.
Quello che è sicuro è che in quel momento a Torino è incorso il processo al cosiddetto nucleo storico delle BR.
Renato Curcio e gli altri Franceschini.
Lo Stato sta processando le BR.
Perciò le BR decidono di processare lo Stato.
Secondo la loro analisi, lo Stato vuol dire la DC.
La DC possiede e gestisce prende integralmente lo Stato.
È un analisi, forse non del tutto sbagliato a essere sinceri, diciamolo pure, certo, troppo rigida.
In ogni caso loro hanno questa idea e la DC che bisogna colpire per colpire lo Stato.
Ma la DC vuol dire tante cose.
C'è Andreotti, c'è Fanfani, c'è Moro, bisogna decidere.
E allora Valerio Morucci e Adriana Faranda sono incaricati di fare qualche indagine.
Per verificare fra questi dirigenti della DC chi è il più vulnerabile.
E cominciano a andare in giro per Roma a verificare.
Andreotti abita in centro e corso vittorio.
Trovarlo è facilissimo.
Addirittura c'è una trattoria dove la sua scorta si ferma a pranzo tutti i giorni.
E per parecchi giorni Morucci e Faranda vanno a pranzo anche loro nella stessa trattoria.
Tanto che alla fine quasi fanno amicizia con la scorta di Andreotti.
Quando si trova lì a pranzo si fanno segno col capo entrando.
Una volta viene a pranzo lì con loro anche Mario Moretti.
Il quale si mette le mani nei capelli quando si accorge che loro si salutano con la scorta di Andreotti.
Però Andreotti anche se è facile da trovare e difficile da porter via, abita in centro, a Roma.
Le strade sono strette.
Bloccare il centro è facilissimo.
I controlli di polizia, siamo nel 78, vi ricordate quanti ce n'erano?
Anche prima del rapimento Moro.
I controlli di polizia sono fittissimi.
Insomma, Andreotti non va bene.
C'è Fanfani.
Andiamo a vedere.
Hanno un indirizzo di Fanfani al Trionfale.
Morucci e la Faranda vanno a vedere quell'indirizzo.
Suono nel campanello.
Fanfani, no, non abita qui.
Dato che non l'hanno trovato, non sanno bene come fare.
E di conseguenza anche Fanfani ridunciano a rapirlo.
Questa è un'altra cosa che vale la pena di ricordarci.
Le BR non sono mica dei super uomini.
Sono una coppia di fidanzati in questo caso.
Morucci di 29 anni e Faranda di 27.
Che vanno a vedere su un citofono se c'è scritto Fanfani.
Non c'è scritto Fanfani e le BR non sono in grado di andare avanti.
Rimerebbe Moro.
E in una riunione uno dei brigatisti dice,
sapete, io,
questo è Franco Bonisoli,
detto il Rossino,
che sarà nel gruppo di fuoco dell'attacco a Moro
e che è uno dei capi delle BR,
sta nell'esecutivo,
Franco Bonisoli dice,
sapete, io un po' di tempo fa, un mattino,
passavo davanti alla Chiesa di Santa Chiara,
alla Camilluccia,
e ho visto parcheggiate due auto blu.
Un buon brigatista a quel punto si ferma a controllare
cosa sta succedendo.
Sono fermato e sapete cosa ho visto?
Ho visto che Moro andava lì a pregare in Chiesa,
prima di andare in ufficio,
a 9 del mattino.
Erano le sue le auto blu con la scorta.
E racconta Bonisoli la mattina dopo,
sono tornato a vedere.
Erano di nuovo lì, alla stessa ora.
Lui fa sempre lo stesso percorso
e si ferma a pregare alla Chiesa di Santa Chiara.
Moro abita fuori dal centro storico,
questa è una cosa importante,
abita a Montemario,
lì il problema del traffico è diverso.
E si ferma alla Camilluccia Santa Chiara a pregare.
Vi do un esempio adesso su questo dettaglio
di come i brigatisti hanno saputo che Moro,
tutte le mattine,
si fermava alla Chiesa di Santa Chiara.
Vi do un esempio dei piccoli dettagli frustranti
su cui esistono versioni contraddittorie,
su cui non possiamo essere sicuri al 100%.
Tutti loro raccontano, appunto,
sì, Bonisoli l'ha visto.
Valerio Morucci racconta una storia diversa.
Valerio Morucci dice che questa storia che Moro
andava a pregare tutte le mattine a Santa Chiara
era già saltata fuori,
in una riunione tre anni prima.
Era la prima volta che quelli del Norma
e quelli del Nord, come dice Valerio Morucci,
erano venuti a Roma per fondare la colonna romana.
Lui non c'era ancora in quella riunione,
è entrato dopo, chissà se dice la verità.
A Morucci i brigatisti venuti da Milano
stanno molto antipatici.
Dice, su Roma la pensavano più o meno come i leghisti.
E comunque quelli del Nord scesi a Roma,
secondo Morucci, si erano portati dietro
come una reliquia, un ritaglio di giornale
in cui si raccontava che l'onorevole Moro,
tutte le mattine, andando a lavorare,
si ferma a sentir messa alla Chiesa di Santa Chiara.
Questo punto è molto difficile sapere se questa storia è vera.
Morucci è uno che scrive bene, ha scritto tanti libri,
gli piacerò manzare, ma insomma a noi non importa.
Era solo per darvi un'idea delle mille piccole cose
su cui lo storico fa fatica a dire quale è la verità.
Ma in ogni caso la sostanza è chiara.
Moro è l'obiettivo più facile.
Nell'autunno del 77, a livello nazionale,
le BR decidono il rappimento di Moro.
E il Comitato Esecutivo delle Brigate Rossi
incarica la Colonna Romana di studiare l'azione.
Come sono organizzate le Brigate Rossi al vertice?
Chi dirige tutto è il Comitato Esecutivo.
Sono in quattro Moretti, Azzolini, Michaletto, Bonisoli.
Al di sopra di loro c'è la direzione strategica delle BR,
ma la direzione strategica è un organismo pesante
in cui ci sono i rappresentanti di tutte le colonne,
15 persone che si trovano.
Quindi la direzione strategica non si può riunire a tutti i momenti.
Arrivà gente da tutta Italia.
È un organismo di indirizzo.
La direzione strategica discute,
prepara i famosi documenti con cui si dà la linea.
Del febbraio del 78, un mese prima del rappimento Moro,
la direzione strategica delle BR si riunisce Sorta,
in una villetta a Velletri, messa a disposizione della Colonna Romana.
E preparano la risoluzione in cui dichiarano che la DC è il nemico numero uno.
Questa risoluzione strategica delle Brigate Rosse,
tanto per dare un'idea della loro capacità di diffusione delle loro idee,
viene stampata in 10.000 copie,
che vengono distribuita nelle fabbriche italiane.
Dopodiché una volta presa la decisione,
la direzione strategica esce di scena,
adesso entra in campo l'esecutivo.
E il legame tra l'esecutivo e la Colonna Romana e Mario Moretti.
Cosa si fa concretamente?
Dobbiamo rapire Moro benissimo.
Dove?
Dobbiamo pedinarlo, studiare le sue abitudini
e capire dove rapirlo.
La prima idea è la Chiesa di Santa Chiara.
Perciò Valerio Moretti e Adriana Faranda,
due fidanzatini che si tengono per mano,
vanno a passeggio alla mattina davanti alla Chiesa di Santa Chiara.
Passano così vicini,
e tutte le mattine le auto della scorta di Moro sono lì.
I due fidanzatini passano accanto alle auto della scorta,
così vicini che sentono i poliziotti che chiacchierano.
Uno di loro dice,
Hai visto? Sono arrivati le rondini.
Fra poco è primavera.
Molti anni dopo Adriana Faranda racconterà a Valerio Moretti
che quella frase le è rimasta impresa
e che le provoca ancora un gruppo in gola,
perché loro stanno passando accanto a quei poliziotti
e devono decidere come rapire Moro
e quanta gente bisognerà ammazzare.
La Chiesa di Santa Chiara per un po' sembra un luogo ideale,
perché Moro entra,
va al primo banco a pregare,
sui cinque uomini di scorta solo due,
e entra, noi si fermano all'ingresso della Chiesa,
gli altri tre restano fuori.
Per cui insomma,
se entriamo in forza e possiamo immobilizzare
i due poliziotti che sono entrati,
non c'è bisogno di sparare,
prendiamo Moro, lo portiamo fuori,
da dove c'è un uscita laterale della Chiesa di Santa Chiara.
Morucci va, viene, inchievi quella Chiesa,
come fosse a casa sua alla fine,
se la studia in tutti gli angoli,
è convinto che si può fare.
Solo che quell'uscita laterale della Chiesa,
da lì si vede un'edicola che c'è sulla strada,
quindi dall'edicola si vede l'uscita,
e tutte le mattine i poliziotti della scorta che restano fuori
a un certo punto vanno a comprare il giornale all'edicola.
Quindi non sarebbe tanto bene,
ma poi viene fuori un'altra cosa,
che l'uscita laterale dà sul cortile di una scuola.
È il cortile di una scuola,
e alle 9 del mattino
è il momento in cui entrano e descono i bambini e le mamme.
Quando si discute di questo all'esecutivo,
si dice no, non si può fare.
Noi non ci mettiamo a rapire Moro
e portarlo fuori in mezzo alle mamme e ai bambini
con il rischio che la scorta reagisca
e che comincia una sparatoria.
Non se ne parla neanche.
Allora, allora dove andiamo a prenderlo?
Moro insegna l'università.
Vanno a vedere all'università, studiare i suoi orari, le aule.
Ci va Antonio Savasta,
che poi sarà uno dei famosi pentiti delle Brigate Rossi.
Segue Moro, va allezione, prende i tempi,
poi torna e dice no ragazzi, non si può mica fare.
Primo, lì è sempre pieno di studenti e sempre pieno di gente.
Secondo, e questo è interessante,
in quel luogo pericoloso che è l'università,
in mezzo a quella gente pericolosa che sono gli studenti,
i poliziotti della scorta di Moro sono sul chi vive,
attentissimi col dito sul grilletto.
Quindi quello è l'ultimo posto dove si può andarlo a prendere.
Allora c'è un'unica soluzione, bisogna prenderlo per strada.
Bisogna bloccare le auto a un certo punto e portarlo via.
Certo in quel caso bisognerà uccidere la scorta.
Tutto questo avviene ad opera di un gruppetto ristrettissimo,
una decina di militanti, non sono mica di più,
la colonna romana delle Brigate Rossi.
Una decina di militanti che vivono, come dicevamo, in clandestinità.
Vivere in clandestinità non è facile.
La prima difficoltà è che ci vogliono i documenti falsi.
Ci sono controlli continui in Italia in quegli anni.
Devi avere le carte a posto, e devi averne tante.
Mario Moretti ha raccontato, sapete quanti documenti falsi ci vogliono
per venire via puliti se ti fermano su una macchina rubata?
Ce ne vogliono otto.
Se non li hai, è meglio girare in tram, altrimenti non duri neanche tre giorni.
Dunque ci vogliono i documenti falsi e bisogna fabbricarli.
Così come si fabbricano le targhe false per le macchine che vengono rubate.
Ci vogliono officine, tipografie e operai capaci.
Ci sono. Le biere sono composte soprattutto da operai.
E i simpatizzanti, quelli che vivono liberamente alla luce del sole
e che però danno una mano, sono quasi tutti operai, tecnici.
Per cui non c'è difficoltà, si trovano quelli che ti fanno le cose.
C'è il compagno tipografo che accette di aprire una tipografia sua alla luce del sole
e poi quando c'è ne bisogno ti stampa di nascosto i comunicati delle biere.
Poi certo ci possono essere degli incidenti.
A un certo punto comprono una stampante, la comprono da un rigattiere.
Questa cosa darà luogo a dietrologie sbalorditive
perché salterà fuori un bel giorno che questa stampante usata dalle biere in tipografia
era stata dismessa dai servizi segreti.
Il fatto che loro usano una stampante che viene dai servizi segreti, ovviamente.
Ecco, Mario Moretti dirà quella stampante avremmo fatto meglio a mangiarci la bullone per bullone.
Ci dava meno grane.
La tipografia dunque è fondamentale.
La tipografia servirà per esempio, pensate ai dettagli di una storia come questa.
Servirà la tipografia per stampare durante il sequestro moro
per falsificare una ricetta che serve per comprare un farmaco di cui moro ha bisogno
e che non gli possono comprare in farmacia senza la ricetta.
Ora è chiaro che per fare tutto questo ci vogliono dei soldi.
Tutta questa gente vive in clandestinità a tempo pieno senza lavorare
e perciò prendono uno stipendio.
Le BR a ogni regolare pagano uno stipendio.
Loro lo chiamano così, sono stipendiati e naturalmente lo stipendio è quello di un operaio,
non una lira di più.
Anzi, Valerio Moretti, che come avete capito nei confronti dei puri,
si è un po' allontanato, Moretti racconta, sapete, i puri riuscivano a non spendere neanche tutto
quello stipendio da operaio che gli veniva versato ogni mese
e se avanzavano qualcosa riportavano indietro.
Erano fuori di testa, dice Moretti.
Da dove vengono questi soldi?
All'inizio facevano rapine.
Rapine in banca, negli uffici postali, loro li chiamano espropri,
ma è molto rischioso ed è molto impegnativo, perché la rapina rende poco.
Bisogna farne tante.
Moretti dice, in pratica facevamo una rapina in banca ogni mese.
Non si poteva andare avanti così, non facevamo nient'altro.
E non basta, molti compagni non erano contenti.
Molti compagni dicevano, ma io non voglio entrare in una banca e gridare mani in alto,
questa è una rapina, noi non siamo delinquenti, siamo comunisti.
Perciò ci ragionano su e decidono che bisogna cambiare sistema.
Bisogna rapire dei grandi industriali e farsi pagare il riscatto.
Molti di noi ricordano che in quell'epoca i rapimenti erano abbastanza frequenti,
in Italia la malavita comune rapiva contro il riscatto, lo fanno anche le BR.
Ne fanno più di uno, poi ne fanno uno grandioso, che li mette a posto per sempre.
Rapiscano Pietro Costa della famiglia di armatori genovesi, Costa Crocera avete presente.
Questo rapimento Costa io adesso ci perderò un pochino di tempo,
perché è una storia che meriterebbe di essere raccontata in un'ora anche quella,
la storia del rapimento Costa.
Pietro Costa è un membro giovane della famiglia.
Le BR lo rapiscano e chiedono il riscatto.
I Costa, armatori genovesi, vecchia scuola, cominciano a negoziare.
Negoziano per tre mesi facendo sempre, costringendo le BR ad abbassare
progressivamente la richiesta del riscatto.
Quando la cifra chiesta delle BR coincide con l'importo dell'assicurazione, i Costa pagano.
Hanno raccontato i brigatisti che quando rilasciano Pietro Costa dopo tre mesi di prigionia,
gli ridanno il portafoglio, lui controlla che ci sia tutto,
e poi dice c'era un biglietto dell'autobus timbrato da una sola parte.
Il fatto è che i brigatisti sono deliziati, li ammirano tantissimo.
Questi sono i veri nemici con cui vale la pena di combattere.
I brigatisti adorano questi industriali vecchio stile che sanno qual è il valore del denaro
e gente con cui si capiscono.
Del resto Moretti lo dirà proprio.
Quando noi rapivamo un industriale o un dirigente d'azienda, con lui ci capivamo subito.
Parlavamo la stessa lingua e parlavamo della stessa cosa.
Noi gli dicevamo il punto di vista degli operai e lui ci rispondeva col punto di vista dei padroni,
mentre dice Moretti quando rapivamo o comunque dovevamo interlocuire con un magistrato o con un politico,
non ci si capiva per niente.
Sapete che con Moro non si sono capiti per niente,
è stato uno dei drambi del rapimento Moro, la fatica di capirsi.
E invece con gli industriali si capiscono.
Questo è un dettaglio ma anche questo, raccontiamolo.
I costa pagano.
Due valigie piene di soldi.
I brigatisti sono lì in un garage con queste due valigie piene di soldi, chiuse.
E hanno paura d'aprirle, perché hanno paura che ci sia il trucco, la bomba.
Si sono procurati delle maschere anti gas e si mettono le maschere anti gas.
E a quel punto non le aprono, le valigie tagliano il coperchio, le valigie sono piene di soldi.
Grande sollievo, ci sono i soldi, si togono le maschere anti gas
e poi appena li maneggiano, si rendono conto che questi soldi, queste banconote, due valigie di banconote,
sono state tutte cosparse di una strana polverina fosforescente.
Tutto ora i brigatisti, quando raccontano questa cosa, non sanno se ridere o piangere, dicono,
ma cosa pensava di fare la polizia?
Il fatto sta che le banconote sono tutte cosparse di polverina fosforescente,
per cui i brigatisti passano le settimane successive a lavare una per una le banconote
con una spugnetta e poi le appendono in bagno con le mollette a dasciugare,
come in un film di Totò, dice Mario Moretti.
Il sequestro Costa rende un miliardo e mezzo di lire, che basta mantenere le BR per quattro anni.
Tutti i soldi sono presi in consegno dal Comitato Esecutivo, che li distribuisce alle varie colonne secondo il bisogno.
Il Comitato Esecutivo tiene i conti e, in teoria, ogni militante ha il diritto di chiedere di vedere i conti.
Moretti dice che non è mai successo, dei soldi non fregava niente a nessuno
e credo che possiamo anche credergli su questo.
Uno degli usi principali dei soldi consiste nel pagarsi degli alloggi.
Bisogna affittare degli alloggi, capite? Chi vive in clandestinità, il punto debole è la casa.
E, tra l'altro, lo Stato lo sa e cerca di stringere proprio sulla casa.
Subito prima del sequestro Moro passa una nuova legge, secondo cui il padrone di casa che affitta un alloggio
deve comunicarlo alla polizia con i dati dei documenti dell'inquilino.
Ora, le Brigate Rossi a Roma hanno come sede principale un ufficio, in via Chiambrera, allo Stienze,
che Valerio Moretti ha preso in affitto sotto falso nome, fingendo di essere un ingegnere che doveva mettere su un'impresa.
Quando esce questa legge della segnalazione alla polizia, Moretti si preoccupa.
Non è che adesso la padrone di casa viene a chiedermi documenti, la fotocopia.
Come, come non è, decide di giocare d'anticipo. Telefona alla padrone di casa.
Dice, signora, ha visto la nuova legge? Signora non sapeva niente.
Moretti le spiega, c'è la nuova legge, dovrebbe compilare dei moduli, portarli alla polizia.
Ma guardi, signora, se vuole, venga qua un momento, ne parliamo.
La padrone di casa va a casa da Moretti, a via Chiambrera.
Moretti le dice, guardi, signora, ho controllato bene.
La legge non era retroattiva, quindi noi siamo a posto.
Però se lei vuole essere proprio tranquilla, se vuole compilare i moduli, li ho già presi.
Ma no, dice la padrone di casa, ma si immagini, lei è una così brava persona.
E dice la padrone di casa, non sa chi c'era qui prima di lei.
C'erano due studenti calabresi.
Avevano perfino una bandiera con la falcia e il martello, pesa al muro.
Secondo me erano delle Brigate Rossi.
Ora, i padroni di casa sono sempre un problema.
Quindi quando vuoi essere veramente sicuro, sicuro l'alloggio devi comprarlo.
L'alloggio in cui sequestrare Moro lo comprano.
Appena ha deciso il rapimento, Mario Moretti cerca un alloggio da comprare con i soldi nel sequestro costa.
Ci sono dei criteri.
Deve essere in un posto anonimo, una via anonima, una palazzina qualunque,
senza portineria, nessuno che tenga d'occhio chi entra e desce, e ci vuole il garage con i box.
Con i box da cui si possa salire all'alloggio rapidamente senza farsi vedere.
Trovano un alloggio che andrebbe proprio bene in una via minuscola che non conosce nessuno, alla Magliana.
Non è vicino alla zona in cui abita Moro e dove probabilmente avrà il rapimento a Montemario.
Però è dalla stessa parte del Tevere e questo è fondamentale.
Quando hai moro nel bagagliaio non puoi rimanere bloccato in un ingorgo al ponte.
La via si chiama via Montalcini.
L'alloggio lo compra una compagna non clandestina, Laura Braghetti, che fa l'impiegata.
Dopo che ha comprato l'alloggio e decidono che per essere proprio sicuri deve avere anche un fidanzato, Laura Braghetti.
Perciò Germano Maccare, un altro brigatista, compare come suo fidanzato e loro insieme cominciano a frequentare questo alloggio
per creare un'apparenza di totale normalità.
Comprano la gabbia con i canarini, la vasca con i pesci rossi, Laura Braghetti fa amicizia con la signora anziana del piano di sopra,
le va a fare la spesa ogni tanto e neanche loro sanno a cosa servirà l'alloggio.
E sempre la compartimentazione, meno sai e meglio è, sanno soltanto che devono aspettare.
E poi alla fine del 77 arriva Mario Moretti e li avvisa che nell'alloggio bisogna fare dei lavori in segreto
per ricavare una stanzetta nascosta insonorizzata, nascosta dietro una finta parete e una libreria come nei romanzi gialli.
E allora anche i due capiscono che si prepara un rapimento ma non sanno mica che sarà moro.
Fino alla fine ci saranno solo quattro brigatisti che conoscono l'indirizzo di Via Montalcini,
sono Laura e Germano che ci abitano e Mario Moretti e però Spero Gallinari.
Il muro per nascondere la stanzetta segreta lo tirano su loro, Moretti e Gallinari, sono operai, sanno fare tutto.
Tirano su il muro, siccome non c'è una finestra mettono una ventola per la erazione, poi problemi ce ne sono sempre.
La prima notte che moro rimane prigioniero lì si accorgono che la ventola fa un rumore bestiale, di notte crea sospetti.
Perciò fanno un accordo con Moro, loro ogni sera terranno aperta la porta per mezz'ora per cambiare l'aria e Moro si impegna in quella mezz'ora non fare rumore.
Beh, ma così siamo andati avanti chiaramente, no? Il rapimento non è ancora avvenuto.
Devono ancora decidere dove esattamente rapirlo e perciò studiano il percorso che Moro fa con le due auto tutte le mattine.
Il percorso è sempre lo stesso. Esce di casa prima delle nove, lui abita via del Forte Triomfale, lo dico per i romani, fa via Triomfale, via Fani, via Stresa, via della Camilluccia.
Si ferma alla Chiesa di Santa Chiara. Lungo tutto questo percorso c'è un unico stop, via Fani angolo via Stresa.
È una via in salita dove quindi le macchine rallentano per forza e in cima c'è lo stop.
Da una parte della strada c'è un bar, ma è chiuso per fortuna perché è fallito.
Dall'altra parte lavora il fioraio, ma quella mattina il fioraio non ci sarà.
Calcolano quanta gente ci vuole. Questo è un altro degli aspetti su cui non siamo sicurissimi.
Anzi, premessa, saprete sicuramente che proprio su quanta e quale gente ha partecipato all'Aguato le dietrologie non si sono mai fermate.
C'erano i tedeschi dell'est, il Kagebe, i palestinesi, i marziani, ogni sorta di cose.
Non sappiamo esattamente quanta gente c'era, ma in realtà io sono abbastanza sicuro che non c'erano i tedeschi dell'est, negli israeliani, negli palestinesi.
C'erano 11 brigatisti di sicuro. Poi non si può escludere che uno o due siano sfuggiti e che i compagni non lebbiano mai denunciati, per cui sono quelli fondamentalmente.
11, ne conosciamo di sicuro. Di cui tre donne.
Mario Moretti ha detto che nelle biere le donne erano importantissime ed assolutamente all'appare con gli uomini.
E se l'è un po' presa con la stampa maschilista che invece parlava sempre di pasionarie o di fidanzatine.
Io ricordo anche di aver visto un'intervista, un brigatista ma non ricordo più chi era, il quale racconta che queste compagnie erano veramente delle dure
e che siccome in clandestinitati manca un po' il rapporto con una donna,
una magari avrebbe anche voluto avere una storia con queste compagnie, ma non era cosa, ecco.
Non era proprio il caso di lasciargli capire che avevi certi pensieri.
11, dunque. Ci vogliono tutti, ci vogliono il gruppo di fuoco, ci vogliono gli autisti, delle varie automobili,
ci vogliono delle vedette, dei gruppi di controllo.
11 uomini e sono troppi. Le Brigate Rosse e Roma non hanno 11 militanti.
Perciò ne fanno venire giù due dal nord, uno da Milano e uno da Torino.
Vengono giù in treno e ripartiranno in treno un'ora dopo l'Aguato.
11, il più giovane ha 23 anni, il più vecchio ne ha 31.
Quelli che devono sparare sono quattro e sono tutti i uomini, che ne dicano Mario Moretti,
però quelli coimitra sono quattro uomini, tra cui Valerio Morucci e Prospero Gallinari.
Quel mattino si decide che saranno travestiti da piloti della l'Italia.
Questa è una cosa che di nuovo ha scatenato dietrologie.
Perché si è detto, ma perché devono travestirsi da piloti della l'Italia?
E allora qualcuno ha detto dovevano essere indivisa perché non si conoscevano.
C'era il super killer mandato dal Mossad, supponiamo,
e siccome non si conoscevano dovevano essere indivisa.
I Brigatisti hanno detto, ma figuratevi un po',
e per un altro motivo che eravamo vestiti da piloti della l'Italia.
Perché voi immaginate in quel momento, in quel contesto storico a Roma,
quattro giovanotti che se ne stanno fermi all'angolo di una strada.
Quanto tempo ci vuole secondo voi, perché è un vicino, telefoni alla polizia?
E se poi la cosa a quel giorno non dovesse andare in porto,
dobbiamo tornare lì il giorno dopo?
Invece quattro piloti della l'Italia tutti li vedono, nessuno li nota.
Pensano che stiano aspettando il pulmino dell'aeroporto.
Poi ci sono anche altri particolari.
L'impermeabile del pilota della l'Italia nasconde benissimo il giubbotto antiproiettile.
I quattro hanno il giubbotto antiproiettile.
E nel borsone della l'Italia ci sta il mitra.
Poi naturalmente ci sono anche i problemi imprevisti,
perché quella mattina, pochi minuti prima che arrivi la macchina di Moro,
i quattro piloti della l'Italia sono lì, all'angolo della strada,
arriva una signora, li vede e avrebbe giusto bisogno di alcune informazioni su dei voli.
Perciò va lì e comincia a chiedere.
I quattro fanno una gran fatica a liberarsi della signora.
Quanto le armi invece non sono un problema.
O meglio, lo sono, ma non procurarsele.
Procurarsele è uno scherzo.
Ancora Moretti.
Cosa credete?
Le armi girano sul mercato come la Coca-Cola.
Però le BR hanno degli scrupoli,
cercano di non comprarle dalla criminalità organizzata, ogni tanto capita.
Per allora preferirebbero evitare.
Preferiscono rubarle.
Oppure si stampano dei permessi e vanno in armeria e le comprano regolarmente.
La tipografia è di nuovo e decisiva.
Poi c'è qualche vecchio partigiano che ancora lo stengna,
scosto in cantina e che si convince a imprestarlo.
E poi ci sono anche i palestinesi.
Quello è l'unico contatto internazionale che le BR hanno sempre riconosciuto.
Con i palestinesi, lo LLP noi dei contatti li avevamo.
E qualche arma ce l'hanno dato a loro.
Però sono armi scadenti, spesso, vecchie, malconce.
Secondo Morucci, che l'avete capito, è molto critico,
e lui e Moretti non si amano per niente.
Secondo Morucci era addirittura una posa.
Per certi capi delle BR andare in giro con armi scassate.
Moretti andava in giro con una pistola malridotta e arrugginita.
E secondo Morucci era così, appunto, per posa, per eleganza.
Poi ci vogliono le macchine.
Ci vogliono molte macchine e vengono tutte rubate nelle settimane precedenti.
Da gente, da compagni, che non sanno a cosa serviranno, chiaramente.
Sanno solo che devono rubare una macchina e consegnarla a qualcun altro.
Rubano macchine dei modelli più anonimi, ovviamente.
Le consegnano a qualcun altro.
Uno che magari ha un'officina.
Oppure semplicemente uno che se la parcheggia sotto casa.
Poi si nascosto si mette una targa falsa.
Chi ha la macchina in consegna dopo qualche giorno la sposta in un'altra via
per non dare nell'occhio.
L'importante è che quel giorno ogni macchina sia al posto giusto
e l'autista la possa prendere in consegna.
Tra le macchine rubate nelle settimane precedenti c'è anche la famosa R4 rossa
in cui sarà poi trovato molto tempo dopo il cadavere di Moro.
La macchina più importante di tutte è una 128 bianca
che dovrà restare parcheggiata in via fani.
E quando le due macchine di Moro si mettono in via fani
la 128 bianca deve uscire dal parcheggio e immettersi nella via davanti all'oro.
E poi arrivata allo stop dovrà fermarsi.
Questa macchina la guida Mario Moretti.
E la macchina, l'attenzione al dettaglio.
Emerge molto spesso questa attenzione maniacale al dettaglio
che però è quella che ti permette di sopravvivere
o comunque che aumenta le chance di successo.
Su questa macchina rubata che dovrà, voi avete capito,
sta arrivando la macchina di Moro.
All'improvviso vede una macchina parcheggiata lì che si mette davanti all'oro.
Questa macchina avrà una targa del corpo diplomatico
che è stata anch'essa rubata qualche mese prima
perché al poliziotto alla guida la targa del corpo diplomatico
gli darà automaticamente sicurezza.
E eviterà che gli vengano dei sospetti.
E poi serviranno altre tre macchine per andare via.
Hanno previsto una 132 per caricarci Moro
e altre 228, una blu e una bianca
perché tutto il gruppo di fuoco possa allontanarsi.
Così arriviamo al 16 marzo 1978.
La notte prima sono arrivati due compagni dal Nord
e si sono incontrati tutti perché bisogna riconoscersi effettivamente.
Poi sono andati a dormire.
Moretti naturalmente come tutti quelli che raccontano poi queste cose
dopo Moretti dice non abbiamo mai addormito, c'era troppa tensione.
Stavo lì a ripassare tutti i dettagli.
Dice Moretti, la solitudine comincia la sera prima.
Quel mattino del 16 marzo è ancora Moretti che è il compito più delicato.
Mezz'ora prima delle nove passa in macchina sotto casa di Moro
per vedere se le auto della scorta sono lì come tutti gli altri giorni.
Sono lì.
Allora Moretti fa il giro di tutti gli altri dieci compagni.
Ognuno sta andando al posto prefissato
e li avverte tutti e dieci che l'operazione si fa.
L'ansia ce l'hanno dentro tutti.
L'hanno detto dopo ma penso che sia credibile.
Moretti ha raccontato che quando arrivava uno che voleva entrare
nelle BR, lui gli diceva, guarda, lo sai cosa stai facendo,
le statistiche sono quelle che sono.
Tra sei mesi, se ti va bene sei in galera, se ti va male sei morto.
I pentiti, solo i pentiti hanno raccontato questo devo dire.
Hanno raccontato che la tensione era tale che c'è stato qualcuno che si è sentito male subito prima,
qualcuno che si è sentito male subito dopo,
c'è uno che subito prima ha dovuto andare al bar a prendersi un cognac,
c'è uno che subito dopo quasi sveniva ha dovuto andare al bar a prendersi un caffè,
la cura italiana per tutti i problemi ovviamente.
Va a sapere, le raccontano solo i pentitica,
non può il dente avvelenato a volte,
ma comunque chiaro che la tensione si tagliava col coltello.
L'attacco in sé è questione di pochi secondi,
però bisogna che tutto si incastri esattamente.
Moretti è parcheggiato in Viafani sulla 128 Bianca.
Ci deve essere qualcuno che gli fa un segnale
per avvertirlo quando le macchine di Moro stanno svoltando.
È una donna, la vedetta, si chiama Rita Al Granati.
Se ne sta all'incrocio con Via del Forte Trionfale, da cui devono arrivare le due auto blu,
è a un mazzo di fiori in mano.
I brigatisti hanno studiato e si sono resi conto che una ragazza ferma che non fa niente può essere notata.
Una ragazza ferma con un mazzo di fiori.
Tutti la vedono, nessuno la nota. È normale.
Perciò Rita in mano un mazzo di fiori.
Moro viaggia su due macchine.
Lui sta su una 130 blu con l'autista
e con il comandante della scorta, il maresciallo Leonardo.
Gli altri tre poliziotti sono dietro su una alfetta.
Quando arrivano la ragazza fa il segnale,
poi sale in vespa e se ne va, lei è finito.
Non ha nessuna idea di cosa succederà.
Non ha nessuna idea di dove porteranno Moro, come non c'era nessuno.
La 128 bianca guidata da Moretti si mette in Viafani, proprio davanti alla macchina di Moro,
e poi inchioda allo stop.
E qui mi fermo un attimo su un altro di quei piccoli misteri stupidi
che non hanno nessun senso, nessun significato
e che però ci ricordano ogni volta come noi stiamo lavorando su testimonianze
e le testimonianze a volte sono contraddittorie in un modo
che allo storico mette il nervoso a dirle verità,
perché dice ma che ti frega di questa cosa?
Dite la verità, ma l'edizione? No, allora.
Secondo Molti, venne fuori al processo,
un'altra finezza, la 128 bianca che si mette poi frena allo stop
per bloccare dietro di sé la macchina di Moro,
aveva le luci degli stop disattivate, apposta.
Perché così quando frena l'autista di Moro
non se ne accorge subito e tampona.
Questa cosa al processo è stata accreditata.
Moretti ha detto, ma siete scemi, ma perché dovevamo tamponarla?
Alzi farci tamponare, scusate.
Non ci serveva mica niente, il tamponamento creava solo problemi.
Una roba del gedere non l'abbiamo fatta assolutamente.
Moretti dice, guardate che io anzi so perfettamente
che non c'è stato in quel momento nessun tamponamento.
Io ho fermato allo stop e mi ricordo perfettamente
che ho visto nello specchietto retrovisore l'autista di Moro
che si è fermato dietro e che poi siccome non ripartivo
mi ha fatto segno con la mano di andare.
Dice Moretti, in quell'istante i compagni aprirono il fuoco.
Ma i giudici del processo per qualche motivo
o questa faccenda del tamponamento ci tenevano enormemente,
sono andati a vedere.
Particolare sul reale, la 130 su cui viaggiava Moro, oggi è esposta in un museo.
È al museo della motorizzazione civile a Roma.
Si va a vederla e si vede che ci sono i segni di tamponamento.
Perciò il processo è deciso che aveva questa storia.
Moretti ha detto, ma neanche per sogno,
mi hanno sì tamponato, ma dopo, quando l'autista di Moro è stato ucciso
e ha mollato i piedi dai pedali e la macchina ha fatto uno scatto in avanti.
Di nuovo, come capite, non credo che possa dipendere il destino di qualcuno
da questo particolare.
Non si capisce prende perché neanche queste cose si riesce a metterle in chiaro.
Poi il resto, invece, si sa abbastanza bene, tutto sommato.
Sono in quattro, tutti dallo stesso lato del Marciapiede,
ovviamente i quattro avviatori.
Anche lì, mille dietrologie sostengono che in base alle traiettorie
dovrebbe essere ci stato un altro che è esceso dalla 128 Bianca di Moretti
e ha sparato dall'altra parte.
Tutti i brigatisti unanimemente hanno detto, ma siete scemi?
Ma sapete cosa vuol dire sparare da due parti della stessa strada?
È ovvio che quelli che sparavano stavano tutti dalla stessa parte.
Nella prima macchina, l'autista e il maresciallo Leonardo sono seduti davanti,
moro e dietro.
È abbastanza facile non colpirlo.
Anche per i brigatisti che non sono affatto dei tiratori scelti.
Questa è una cosa che di nuovo è il caso di sottolineare
perché molti di noi si ricorderanno le formule che circolavano allora,
la geometrica potenza del gruppo di fuoco delle BR.
Tutte le testimonianze ci hanno detto il contrario.
Noi non sparavamo quasi mai, dice Moretti.
Io avrò sparato due volte in vitamia col mitra.
Come si fa secondo voi allenarsi all'uso del mitra?
Dove che trovi il posto dove puoi allenarti a usare un mitra?
Perciò, dice Moretti, noi eravamo dei principianti, dei dilettanti.
E i nostri mitra facevano schifo.
Su 4, 2 si sono inceppati durante l'azione.
Solo che anche la scorta è armata male.
Il maresciallo Leonardo ha la pistola in un borsello sotto il sedile.
L'autista ha la pistola in un borsello nel cruscotto.
L'unico mitra in dotazione è nel bagagliaio dell'alfetta.
Lo trovano i brigatisti quando in quei pochi secondi,
dopo aver trascinato Moro nella macchina,
frugano ancora le due macchine alla ricerca delle borse di Moro.
Altro aspetto che, come sapete, darà poi luogo a infinite discussioni,
sono saltate fuori tutte le borse di Moro, pure no, chi le ha prese, chi le ha nascoste.
Fatto sta che i brigatisti le cercano, non le trovano tutte,
però nel cofano trovano questo mitra e se lo prendono, ovviamente.
Il pentito Patrizio Peci dirà poi
il mitra che abbiamo preso alla scorta di Moro era arrugginito, quasi inutilizzabile.
Del resto lo dirà anche Moro, che durante la prigionia, come sapete, scrive, scrive tante lettere,
il 4 aprile dalla prigionia Moro scrive a Zaccagnini.
Se la scorta non fosse stata per ragioni amministrative,
del tutto al disotto delle esigenze della situazione, io forse non sarei qui.
Due mitra su quattro dei brigatisti si inceppano
e uno dei poliziotti della seconda macchina riesce a scendere.
A tirar fuori la pistola e comincia a sparare, si chiama Raffaele Giozzino.
Ovviamente tutti lo prendono di mira.
I due brigatisti che hanno ancora il mitra, gli altri con le pistole.
Raffaele Giozzino ècrivellato da 17 colpi.
Secondo le perizie sono sparati 91 colpi in tutto,
di cui 45 colpiscono i 5 uomini della scorta.
Uno degli agenti è ancora vivo, in realtà morirà all'ospedale,
ma insomma possiamo dire che la scorta è stata esterminata.
A quel punto Mario Moretti tira fuori Moro dal sedile posteriore.
Gli hanno chiesto se Moro ha reagito.
Ma no, dice Moretti, non ha detto una parola.
Eravamo sotto scioca anche noi, figuriamoci lui.
Lo caricano sulla 132 che intanto è arrivata da Via Stresa
e se ne vanno, con quella e con le altre macchine.
Quattro macchine in tutto.
Prima di lasciare l'angolo tra Via Stresa e Via Fani,
un dettaglio che io non conoscevo e che ho trovato incredibile,
anche se è irrilevante.
Tra tutte le persone che abitano lì e che, sentendo sparare,
si affacciano alla finestra, c'è l'onorevole Pino Rauti,
neofascista, estremista, famosissimo all'epoca,
che abita lì in Via Stresa e quel mattino si affaccia
e vede le macchine che ripartono ai morti per terra.
Non vuol dire niente, però è una di quelle cose,
di quei dettagli che ti lasciano stupefatto.
Le macchine filano tutte, sono tre,
ma se neanche una quarta hanno previsto una macchina di copertura
che si mette in testa alla colonna,
filano via alla massima velocità, quattro macchine,
una dietro l'altra, li hanno detto,
ma è non farvi vedere e mortetti a risposta,
ma figurati, in quel momento non era importante non farsi notare.
La sparatoria si sente a un chilometro.
L'essenziale era andare via di lì in fretta.
Si allontanano alla massima velocità.
Si fermano un po' più in là, a piazza Madonna del Cenacolo.
Controllano di esserci tutti.
Anche voi controllate l'orologio giustamente,
ma siamo quasi alla fine.
A quel punto lì si dividono.
I due del Nord vanno alla stazione Termini
e prendono il treno per tornare a casa.
Quasi tutti gli altri filano a casa
attaccati alla televisione e alla radio,
per sentire cosa diranno.
Le auto vengono tutte abbandonate
e saranno ritrovate nei giorni seguenti.
Lì, a piazza Madonna del Cenacolo,
Moro viene trasbordato su un furgone preparato in precedenza.
Nel furgone c'è un cassone di legno che hanno fabbricato.
Ci può stare un uomo dentro, scomodo.
Moretti racconta che quando poi l'hanno tirato fuori dal cassone
per portarlo nell'alloggio segreto,
a Moro gli hanno chiesto scusa, perché il cassone era scomodo.
Sono quelle stranezze della natura umana.
Comunque il furgone riparte, guida Moretti
ed avanti c'è un'altra macchina con due compagni di Scorta.
Fra tutti quanti solo Moretti e Gallinari sanno dove si sta andando.
Avvia Montalcini, ma non subito.
C'è tutto un percorso.
Si avvicinano alla zona,
su un percorso calcolato in precedenza,
per stradine di periferia, quasi di campagna.
A un certo punto prendono addirittura una stradina privata,
che sulle carte non c'è neanche,
e che loro hanno individuato in precedenza per lustrando.
Questa stradina privata è chiusa da una catena.
Loro tagliano la catena con una tronchese e si infilano di lì.
La previsione del dettaglio.
Hanno una tronchese su ogni veicolo,
perché non si sa mai cosa succede,
ma chiunque arrivi lì deve poter passare.
Il calcolo si rivele esatto.
Moltissimi testimoni hanno visto filar via le quattro macchine.
Nessuno li ha più visti.
Lungo il percorso hanno addirittura parcheggiato
un'altra macchina rubata con un'autista,
che sta lì solo nel caso che ci sia bisogno di qualcosa.
Invece non c'è bisogno di niente.
Arriva una destinazione,
cioè al parcheggio sotterraneo della standa dei colli portuensi.
Una grande standa, grande parcheggio sotterraneo,
pieno di gente che carica e scarica roba,
e nessuno nota un cassone che viene scaricato da un furgone
e caricato su una macchina.
E' la macchina di Laura Braghetti,
l'inquilino di Via Montalcini.
E' l'unica macchina che non è stata rubata,
è davvero la sua macchina.
Lei abita lì, i vicini la conoscono,
quella macchina non sospettice nessuno.
Vanno dritti al garage di Via Montalcini.
Non sono ancora le dieci,
un'ora dopo, e moro e già nella stanza segreta.
E qui la nostra storia è quasi finita,
perché ovviamente ne comincia un'altra,
che non racconteremo stasera,
e che non è ancora facile raccontare.
La storia che vi ho raccontata
è una storia, è una meccanica di avvenimenti,
lo vedete, si può ricostruire.
La storia della prigionia di Moro,
delle trattative segrete,
della linea della fermezza,
delle lettere di Moro,
è una enorme storia italiana
che va ancora studiata.
È la storia delle ricerche
che non approdano a niente,
dei misteri non ancora risolti,
noi non la raccontiamo.
Vi racconto qualche dettaglio
giusto per darvi un'idea del clima.
Come il Telex,
che quel mattino,
appena informato del rapimento di Moro,
il capo del Luci Goss,
l'ufficio centrale
per le investigazioni generali
e le operazioni speciali,
che sarebbe l'FBI italiano in sostanza,
quel mattino, il capo del Luci Goss, Antonio Fariello,
manda a tutte le prefetture e le questure
un messaggio cifrato,
attuare immediatamente il piano zero.
In tutte le prefetture e le questure d'Italia
si grattano la testa.
Cosa è il piano zero?
Vanno a vedere nei cassetti,
vanno a vedere in cassa forte.
Piano zero nessuno sa cosa sia.
L'unica questura dove sanno cos'è
è la questura di Sassari,
dove fino a poco tempo prima
era quest'ora il dottor Fariello,
adesso capo del Luci Goss,
in quale a Sassari aveva trovato in cassa forte
un piano di mobilitazione
delle forze dell'ordine di Sassari
in caso di sequestro di persona,
cosa che, come sapete,
all'epoca in Sardegna avveniva spesso.
Dopodiché il dottor Fariello era convinto
che il piano zero esistesse
in tutte le questure d'Italia,
quindi manda quest'ordine.
Però, appunto, ci sono delle reazioni
immediate dello Stato che sono meno comiche,
anzi, o meglio, che possono esserlo,
ma che possono essere riviste in due modi.
Ve ne faccio un esempio.
Quello stesso pomeriggio
il Ministro Cossiga,
Ministro dell'Interno,
comunica alla stampa
i nominativi e le fotografie
di venti sospettati.
E questa cosa si può raccontare
appunto in due modi opposti.
Se vogliamo continuare
il piano zero, allora vi dirò
che su venti nominativi
due sono di persone
che sono già in carcere.
Altri due, con relative fotografie,
sono tutte due di prospero gallinari.
Una senza baffia con nome vero,
una con i baffi e con il nome falso.
Un altro ancora
è un informatore dei carabinieri,
ma il Ministro non lo sapeva.
Però, se guardiamo la storia
da un altro punto di vista,
fra quei venti nominativi
sono cinque dei veri responsabili
del sequestro Moro.
C'è Moretti, c'è Gallinari
e c'è tutto il resto dell'esecutivo,
Bonisoli, Azzolini, Michaletto.
Insomma, non partivano proprio da zero.
Tanto che rimane aperta
la questione di come mai non han trovato niente.
Nonostante l'enorme
e con uno storico
l'ha chiamato l'insensato
di spiegamento
di forze di quelle settimane,
con una media in Italia
ogni giorno
di 1.300 posti di blocco
e ogni giorno
700 perquisizioni domiciliari.
Alla fine
risulteranno perquisite 6 milioni di persone
in Italia.
E ovviamente, il fatto che non abbiamo
trovato niente, anche lì,
alimenta le dietrologie.
Poi, però, io volevo finire...
No, era in certo fra due finali,
ma ve li do tutti e due.
Una cosa che a me sembrate interessante
e tutte e due sono legate all'unico successo
che hanno avuto le forze dell'ordine
in quel periodo, la scoperta del cosiddetto
covo di Via Gradoli,
che era effettivamente una base
delle BR a Roma dove dormivano Moretti
e Barbara Balzerani e viene scoperta
durante quel periodo.
Una cosa che io ho trovato affascinante
è l'elenco
l'inventario
di ciò che è stato trovato nel covo di Via Gradoli.
Un cassetto dell'armadio contiene
una pistola mitragliatrice
un fucile da caccia
una pistola calibro 6.5
una pistola FFC K
altra pistola FFC K
una pistola beretta
un'impugnatura per pistola, caricatore, etc.
è solo un cassetto dell'appartamento.
Poi, naturalmente, nel frigorifero
porzioni di salame,
mortadella, provolone
sulla mensola, barattolo di marmellata,
burro, scatola di dadi, star
di caccia.
Valigietta 24 ore
un giubbotto antiproiettile
e una borsetta di plastica
con un SSR da tua letta per donna.
L'elenco di tutti i senatori
della settima legislatura
libri gialli, libri di fantascienza
fumetti di Charlie Brown
documenti di identità falsi
timbri falsi di uffici di ogni genere
targe di auto rubate
divise palette della polizia
pacchetti di sigarette
goluase, caporal, MS
fumavano forte
copie di quotidiani
il Corriere della Sera
aperto alla pagina
in cui si racconta la vittoria di
Moser a non so più quale gara
pomodori star, piselli di Rica
Fagioli Cirio
Ecco, questa è una cosa che per
lo storico forse non è così significativa
non lo è per niente, però
da un'idea dell'atmosfera italiana
che si poteva respirare
anche nel più pericoloso
covo delle BR
dove appunto
pasta buitoni naturalmente
e barilla, entrambi i tipi
pasta corta, niente spaghetti
l'altra cosa connessa
al covo di Via Graddoli
e con cui veramente questa volta finiamo
è la storia che, anche qui
non so dove ci porta, ma è troppo bella per non raccontarla
della seduta spiritica
e il 2 aprile
domenica
moro in mano alle BR
le ricerche continuano frenetiche
e in una casa di campagna fuori Bologna
si incontrano a passare
la domenica a un gruppo di amici con le famiglie
siccome piove
decidono di fare una seduta spiritica
e di chiedere agli spiriti dove è nascosto
moro
non sono degli amici qualunque
sono tutti i professori dell'università di Bologna
uno di loro si chiama Romano Prodi
fanno la seduta spiritica
siccome sono tutti cattolici di sinistra
evocano gli spiriti di Don Sturzo
e di Giorgio Lapira
gli chiedono dove si trova moro
e il piattino si muove
e forma una parola
Graddoli
cose gradoli cose gradoli
vanno a vedere, gradoli un paesino
in provincia di Viterbo
e mettono sul tavolo una carta geografica
il piattino guidato dalla Pira
si muove
e finisce bothersse sulla provincia di Viterbo
ora questa è già una cosa se vogliamo
abbastanza bizzarra, ma la cosa più bizzarra
è come mai noi sappiamo tutto questo
perché il giorno dopo
il professor Prodi, tornato a Bologna
va alla Digos
e racconta di questa seduta spiritica
da cui è venuto fuori il nome Graddoli
il giorno dopo ancora il professor Prodi va a Roma
e parla di questa faccenda
al Capo dell'Ufficio Stampa della DC
il Capo dell'Ufficio Stampa della DC
va al Ministero
e ne parla un collaboratore di Cossiga
ministra dell'interno
il collaboratore di Cossiga parla
della seduta spiritica al Capo della Polizia
il Dottor Parlato
e il giorno dopo il Dottor Parlato
ordina un rastrellamento
al Paese di Graddoli
sulla base della seduta spiritica
la notizia ovviamente
non viene fuori niente
la notizia della seduta spiritica
circola talmente tanto
fra gli intimi che anche
Eleonora Moro, la moglie di Moro
viene a saperlo
e lei racconterà che ha detto
un funzionario della Polizia
ma non è che magari invece è il nome di una via
il funzionario di Polizia ha risposto
alla signora Moro
a Roma non risulta nessuno via Graddoli
poi se ne ricorderanno tutti
due settimane dopo
quando in una palazzina in periferia
i vicini chiamano i vigili del fuoco
perché c'è una perdita d'acqua
i vigili del fuoco sfondano la porta
c'è davvero una perdita d'acqua
ed è quell'alloggio di via Graddoli
di cui vi ho descritto il contenuto
un attimo fa
l'alloggio di Moretti e Balzerani
chi dice che le coincidenze
non esistono
dice Università di Bologna
lì
l'autonomia operaia era molto forte
le voci circolavano
qualcuno dei professori
avrà sentito questo nome
Graddoli
non voleva compromettersi
ha pensato
alla seduta spiritica
per trasmettere l'informazione
senza che si sapesse da chi veniva
io non so se non è peggio
il tacon del buzo come si dice
perché in ogni caso l'idea
e poi la polizia va a fare i rastrellamenti
perché gli hanno detto che una seduta spiritica
è venuta fuori un nome
ci dice
quale era la situazione in quel momento in Italia
e ci dice forse qualcosa
e qui davvero abbiamo finito
su questo nostro paese
dove anche la tragedia
è sempre un pelo dal finire in farsa
grazie